[Music]
you gotta be kidding me you're gonna
risk the entire mission for a mental
defective dress as a cord justice it's
coming from a guy that wears a toilet
seat on his head we don't leave one of
our own behind hopefully harley's still
alive
no funny business these are dangerous
people team two is clear to go
fire uh three two what are you guys
doing
what you were here to save you you were
gonna save
me it was a really good plan too well i
can go back inside and you can still do
it that's patronizing i'm so sorry
harley quinn bloodsport
[Music]
you know the deal successfully complete
the mission you get 10 years off your
sentence
[Music]
you fail to follow my orders in any way
can i detonate the explosive device in
the base of your
this is the skull suicide squad
any questions
and yes that is your hand very good
we're all gonna die i hope so
oh for [ __ ] sake here's the deal
we fail a mission you die we find out
any information you give us is false
you die if we find out you have
personalized license plates
you don't what no if you cough without
covering your mouth harley although that
isn't an open invitation for you to
cough without covering your mouth
what's the plan how the hell must listen
up you're the leader you're supposed to
be decisive and i've decided that you
should eat a big bag of dicks
if this whole beach was completely
covered in dicks and somebody said i'd
eat every dick until the beach was clean
for liberty i would say no problem why
would someone put
penises all over the beans well that's
why mad men do what they do
this is suicide well that's kind of our
thing
[Music]
are you worried i'm gonna get you out of
your life i'm going to get you
out of here alive
[Applause]
oh my god we've got a freaking kaiju up
in this [ __ ]
like angels are splooting all over us
[Music]
you